[MUSIC]
Why would the banks disrupt themselves by
introducing a digital currency that would
make it easier for consumers and
businesses to dis-intermediate the banks?
Well, the banks may not be the innovators.
It may be that they are the reactors,
that they will react when others innovate.
And I'm sure that they've consider
the trade offs involved in whether
to disrupt themselves by
introducing digital currencies,
or whether to wait and react when
others introduce digital currencies.
Right now digital currency
sounds very edgy and
kind of alternative lifestyle,
but it's becoming the mainstream.
And so, the largest banks in
particular are very aware of this,
they're investing in the technology,
and they will provide this service
as soon as it's profitable enough,
after considering the cost
to them of losing some of their current
business that they're going to disrupt.
Banks will eventually either be leading,
or following, but they'll be involved.
They can't avoid it.
[MUSIC]